have you always had thick skin when it
comes to writing criticism
god no um i'm not even convinced i have
thick skin
now because i i'm i'm very good at
taking a note from someone and trying to
figure out
like how to fix it or if i don't
understand the note like how to find the
note within the note sort of thing
and see like if what the the deeper
problem is
to fix it overall but i still
there are still some notes that make me
upset where i'm like
how could you not understand this it's
right there on the page
um yeah so it doesn't happen as
frequently as it did when i was younger
and was newer
but and i try to keep that at bay or if
like if something
even irks me just a little bit like
thank you for the note and then i'll
come back to it later and be like okay
maybe there was something there let's
take a look at it calm myself down
uh but nobody's perfect and i sure as
hell i'm not either
what would you tell someone who wanted
to quit their day job
today so that they could pursue
screenwriting full-time don't do that
don't do that again like there's i
couldn't find the chapters in the book
uh in a quick but you're not
you're not going to get rich right away
and you're definitely not going to get
rich
right away without having some way to
pay your rent
and there's no reason to go homeless
in the pursuit of it like there are
plenty of people
uh what's her name jk rowling like she
was
going again like how many like hundreds
of rejections before her book finally
got picked up
if she didn't have her job like she
would've been like homeless like
even more because i've read stories
where she couldn't feed her kids or
whatever
it's like that would have been even
worse if she had quit her job to write
that book
you don't quit your job until you even
and even once you've had a success you
know unless it's a tv thing where now
your new job is
writing in a writer's room um because
like i said
even if you sold your script for a
hundred thousand dollars
after you pay all your stuff you got
like forty thousand dollars and how much
are you making in the year right like
compare that to your job
like sure if you want to take a year off
but don't if you're
quitting it to start pitching stuff
that's insane i'm sorry
you like you need to pay rent you need
to
eat you need to feed your kids and
family if you have that
uh your dog would appreciate having some
food as well
like do not quit your job until
you are making enough of an impact where
you can just survive on the
screenwriting what do you want
20 year olds to know about screenwriting
20 year olds
all right it's been a long time for me
i'm 36 now so
uh okay so not
everything has to be a video game or
comic book in movie form
those are great but not every movie has
to be like and they're not going to buy
your superhero script unless it's from
an ip
uh i've made the mistake of writing my
own superhero
and nobody cares because it's not it
doesn't already have the audience you
know
that's whereas horror you can come up
with original horror movies and it's
awesome we want to see it you can come
up with awesome action movies
it's original we want to see it don't
don't write adaptations
there's a don't write adaptations of
things you don't own the rights to
instagram don't write an original
superhero movie because nobody cares
unless it's an adaptation
it's a very oh interesting thing yeah so
if you can get the rights to a superhero
by all means
get the rights and then write it but
don't write your own superhero
and don't try to writing that adaptation
of something you don't own the rights
to i've seen a lot of people in the
forums like on facebook who
are wanting to write their own
spider-man movie
you don't own the rights of spider-man
no one will ever see that in fact they
may even try to sue you if you try
sending it to the people who do own the
rights to it so
um i made that mistake once again when i
was
first starting out i wrote a superhero a
superman script not knowing i couldn't
do anything with it
um i wrote an adaptation of the vagina
monologues
uh not knowing that i couldn't do that
and i got touched with people found out
the rates already owned so blah blah
blah
didn't work um that's that's the thing
don't don't adapt something you don't
own because you're just gonna be
disappointed and waste your time
what about advice to 20 year olds on
mindset like don't get too high or too
low
i think when you're younger and you come
here and everybody's so in awe of young
people
in hollywood um it's easy to really
to go on these roller coaster rides
because people are telling you how
amazing you are
or they're either telling you you're not
and then
they just told you yesterday you were
right so
don't let um rejection
hurt you too bad because they're not
necessarily rejecting you the person
they're rejecting your script
and a lot of people seem to take a
rejection of the script as a rejection
of them personally like like as if
if because i didn't like your script i
hate you i don't hate you
i don't know you you could be a
wonderful person
but i don't like your script it's not
it's not a great story
i'm sorry um but it has nothing to do
with the person so don't let the
rejections
be personal for you and on the flip side
don't rejoice at every minor
success or something that even looks
like a minor success because it can
still fall through
i can't tell you how many times i've had
this amazing looking deal that then just
gets
yanked out from under me for whatever
reason you know i would
i had a producer a few years ago who was
going to pay me like 20 grand
to write a pirate movie for him
and then all of a sudden his investor
who was giving him it was it was for
like
like an 80 million dollar budget or
something like that and
then he was like oh i have the money
blah blah i'm gonna send you the stuff
i'm going to send you the 20 000 check
to start writing like next week
didn't hear from him next week didn't
get a check so i call him up oh yeah so
my investor dropped out
um or another one where i was supposed
to get hired to write a sequel to
a a horror movie and then like
the producer just stopped communicating
with me all of a sudden
no reason given just stopped uh i even
had one producer who literally
died during our negotiations
so that didn't happen you know so it's
like there's always always something
that can make it go wrong so don't
start celebrating until the check is
cleared is
the the the rule of thumb i've got on
that like i i'm
it's fabulous that people are interested
in my stuff but
until like there's a contract sign and
money in my hand
it could go wrong at any time and even
after then they're still playing movies
that
sell for millions of dollars the script
and then the movie never comes out you
know so
uh stuff dies in development hell every
day you know uh
so nothing is a success until it's
100 successful what's your favorite
movie about the industry
i really like trumbo uh that was a
really fantastic movie
um why did you like it aside from brian
yeah cranston's amazing in almost
everything he's even greeting that new
mountain dew commercial are you kidding
me um
he's fantastic seeing how the industry
was at that time
is interesting to learn there's been
other movies that have shown that like
you may have not seen the majestic with
jim carrey where he played a
screenwriter
who ended up getting blacklisted you
know um because they thought that he was
a communist or whatever
and there's the same time period and so
it's very interesting to see
how the the
all the world of hollywood is being
shaped by hearsay
yeah um and then to still see
how trumbo and his friends kind of like
circumnavigated the issue
in a creative clever way like yeah they
took a huge cut in their paychecks but
they
still did what they love you know and
yeah it was just a really interesting
look at
what the the industry was like back then
and then how people could get around
that um
and how they all changed today and then
again brian cranston's a
freaking genius
you